okay
a quick overview of topics i have to
motivate the topic a bit
because it's not quite a typical
computer science topic
i mentioned already that i'll talk about
e ip
and how i p can be managed
how it's generated how it can be
protected
how it can be valued the valuation is
really the crucial
item here and then once all that happens
much of it gets offshored and outsourced
and actually retired from stanford i
think it's
about 13 years ago now and ever since
during most of this time i've actually
been consulting
for the u.s treasury on valuing
intellectual property experts which is a
very odd job very few people do it
and i've been able to put it together in
a book
which was very difficult because i can't
give credit
to what i learned for the is i can
mention any companies that have actually
investigated you know i and that's quite
a number
you know of them by now but through that
there has
a pattern has emerged and that pattern
is very quickly abstracted in
in velvet in this talk
i've looked at more companies
probably in that sense than anybody else
because
because i'm doing this as a specialist
and if you work
for the government you're not even
allowed to share information from one
company to the other
and an iis official in a large company
is assigned to that company
permanently for many years so they
typically don't get a broad assessment
so the fact that i have gotten a broad
assessment is helpful
this was a bit alluded to already
when people talk in computer science
about
economics they talk about the cost of
writing software costs to
build products and capabilities
but once they're done
they walk away typically
and then it's up to business people
economists and lawyers and promoters
to value the work of course they all
have their own agenda
and the results are often quite
inconsistent
so the motivation for this talk here is
a little bit to deal
with the issues that people read in the
newspaper about and
don't understand typically you know one
headline often is that u.s multinational
corporations
now have about two trillion dollars in
tax havens
that's quite a lot of money you know
that's 15
of the public debt so if it would you
know if that would come back
it would the taxes on that would pay off
15 of the u.s public debt
you know these are not small travel
amounts
you have to work with the treasury for
some time before you get
you know comfortable with dealing with
millions
billions trillions and etc
most people glaze over once the zeros
become too much
so most of those companies
that holds us money actually technical
innovators
many right here in the silicon valley
area the
union you know you know that we all love
and we may wonder or admire them when we
find out that they pay two percent taxes
but since we don't know how it happens
you know
we we you know we listen to this
statement
and the ceo or cfo will state
it's perfectly legal so it must be all
right
so i number these things because i'm
showing where the funny things
happen
the the argue oh we shouldn't bring it
back
because if i bring that money back 40
would go to taxes and i'd be so much the
poorer
right another argument is
that that the iss is wimpy and it lets
this big corporations of the hook
you know by hook or crook or bribery
and of course then when when the
politicians come
comes along he says these loopholes
should be plugged
yeah it turns out there are no loopholes
you know it's it's not a little dutch
boy that can stick a finger in the dike
other people blame ireland as a tax
haven because it has a 12 and a half
percent tax rate
and that's why we are losing all that
money
obviously if you transfer your income
to a twelve and a half percent tax haven
you still pay more than
two percent tax you know other
consistency that people don't realize
and and the other thing just give up an
income tax and do it all as sales taxes
but the question there is where are
things being sold
and how are they being sold so on the
whole there's a lot of
lack of understanding
to understand what's going on to
understand
a little bit the overall economic model
the big green square that i have here
indicates
kind of public and private investments
those are needed what gets started
you know out of you know
from you know from stanford which
depends
also still on public investment you know
plus all the tuition that people pay
you you derive common knowledge that's
available to anybody
if you have a company and my company
my abstract company is called mnc for
multinational corporation
it holds intellectual capital which is
private to it
that intellectual capital has two
components
namely the know-how of the workforce
and then the actual intellectual
property they interact together
having intellectual property without
people that understand it doesn't do
doesn't do much good right having people
that are smart
without intellectual property doesn't
allow you to have a business
so that generates technology it also
generates value in
trademarks it all gets integrated
and you get high value products
my daughter-in-law gave the name for the
product
that mnc generates it's a maniac
i have to be aware that there was a
maniac computer actually
built many years ago but
i forgot at the moment we built it if
you have very
high value products you have high sales
margins
the kind of products that silicon valley
makes
i see margins from 60 to 30 percent
profits on the sale price
similar profits you know can be made
from drugs
and then other high value items
and then from that taxes should be paid
could be
paid and then it goes the loop closes if
you don't have that intellectual
property then you just produce commodity
products
they have routine earnings
if you have nothing original you can
charge between five or seven percent
over the price of what it costs you to
make it
if you charge much more somebody else
will compete with you because there's no
barrier to competition so it is very
valuable
to have intellectual property so in a
business three parts have value
contribute value in the business means
it contributes to profit
there's tangible goods the building
computers capital that's what karl marx
worked
about that is what capital is and well
and quite frankly
many of the advice that today's
economists that were you know taught
many in the 1930s or 40s still advise
you know is to have capital goods
and those are visible and those are
shown on the book and the accountants
know what to do with it
but not as visible on the books is the
know-how
of management and employees
and then the intellectual property that
is created there
the design the software the methods and
the trademarks that
belong to the company
the latter two that make up the
intellectual capital of the company
there's actually two words there for
owned is if it's owned it's intellectual
property
if you look at its manifestation it's
called intangible property
very similar terms very very overlapping
and it really means from what size you
look
so intangibles are product of knowledge
and they are characterized that the cost
of the original
is much more than the cost of making
copies
that holds for books made by author
software made by programmers
inventions by engineers trademarks
generated through advertising know-how
of managers
and also customer loyalty becomes ever
less tangible
all of them interact with quality in the
product
so the value in a business is a formula
i'm quoting here somebody it's one to
sell
coke and another thing to sell the
formula
for coke but you have to make coke
in order to profit from having the
formula
you know just having the formula
and not being able to make coke doesn't
do much but it's a commodity bottler
that makes the coke for you the
commodity bottle
gets his six percent and you rake in the
rest
so just this is just an overview so you
can see them nested their intellectual
resources
public and private there's intellectual
capital
owned by a business the intellectual
assets within that intellectual assets
are those that carry
that can be transferred that will be an
important issue
how do you transfer you know the value
of the company and within that is again
the intellectual property
so i mentioned already the two sources
of profit
routine earnings and non-routine
earnings
very different ratios if you're a
silicon valley company
you want to be at the bottom not at the
top
people probably know about iip
ip can be protected from theft so that
you really own it
you can have patents copyright
and the most important value item in
modern business is actually trade secret
you protect that through nda only things
that are very obvious you would you
bother doing by patenting if
intel has a better process for
increasing the yield on its
chips it would not publish that as a
patent
so amd could use it because
how could intel inspect amd factories
whether they're using
a similar process so on
furthermore it's a fast moving world
takes a long time to get patents out
keeping trade secrets is risky they can
walk out of the door
but since things go go fast
try to keep your people and so
in the cases that i deal with typically
of the intellectual property is actually
protected by trade secret once you do
the valuation
this is again a warning because so many
people
measure intellectual output by number of
patents being issued
you know patents are issued by companies
that are in a competitive situation
and when one have have have collections
of patents to trade
it's a very incomplete metric of how
successful you are in generating
intellectual property
another valuable thing can be
contractual rights that you have
obtained
you know if you have the right to supply
all the cell phones to verizon that's a
very valuable item
to have relations with customers with
suppliers
so so we're dealing
here always with protected value
and the people are kind of hard to
protect so
there's actually a lot of effort made to
protect your rights relative to the
people
you you offer stock options bonuses
also pride and pride in the work
you know and that's a very important
value
you know when when people got unhappy at
yahoo
a lot of people walked out smart people
walked out of the door
because they no longer had pride in the
company
and so they lost a lot of intellectual
capital
so so things were never measurable on
the books
you know just even counting employees is
not a good metric there
once you have intellectual property you
can assemble it into
an ip box that's actually
a term used in the licensing field
and and you can sell that box or you can
license the box if you sell it you don't
control it anymore
if you license it you're still in
control
you can also hack the bark into amazing
pieces
you know and sell pieces of it you know
trenches
you know for instance you can decide
that you give all the rights for
what you're producing to a deal in japan
because you could decide
you cannot deal with the japanese market
you know so now you have given
everything that you have
but only a geographic trench away
so but you know by doing that you can
convert even
tangibles to intangible rights
if you have a big building when you want
to get some cash out
you can sell it to a real estate agent
with an agreement you you lease it back
nothing will change except maybe a brass
plate at the bottom
of the building right and maybe the door
where the janitor's work gets
you know has a new name nothing changes
but you have sold the right to tangible
property and the right
to both tangibles and intangibles is an
intangible right
that you can sell split market in very
arbitrary ways
if you don't want to hire
a fancy real estate person but want to
do the same trick
and save on taxes you can set up a
real estate corporation in the virgin
islands
or the bahamas or somewhere right it's
it
it's your cooperation you sell your
rights
to that you know that corporation
it could only be a mailbox right
but that corporation now when it makes
income
pays taxes in the cayman island for its
since you're st it's still in your group
the the you know the books that show up
don't don't notice it
the only thing that you'll notice that
your tax rate
has gone down because you're not paying
as much taxes anymore
now we and and i use a building because
then
it's kind of easier to explain so so now
we have an
electronics company let's say and they
make gadgets here in california
they're distributing them to emea is
kind of the
term always for europe middle east and
africa because there tends to be
one sales unit typically
you know the far east and
well in latin america and they sell
there
and the income from their sales flows to
you
and it's profits for you
but frequently that goes along now with
some offshoring of work
right you can move work to lower cost
countries
if you move work to lower cost countries
you have to provide the ip
there too hiring a smart
engineer in india for one fifth of the
cost
doesn't pay you anything that if you
don't provide him
with the ip that he needs in order to
work on your stuff and to make progress
so you also move
rights to the ip where the ips
physically doesn't mean much
but instead of moving it to india you
might as well move it to a tax haven
the rights and then
to keep the books clean when when your
engineers work in
india they have to license
the rights to the software from your tax
haven company
because uh now india has roughly the
same tax rates as the united states
right but
you make sure that the license fees
is such that india gets
jobs maybe even a commodity profit
if there's a actual factory there but
the remaining profits
those 50 minus of 60 percent
now flow to the tax haven
so so people look at offshore
has only been moving jobs
but one of the reasons it's attractive
is that you can do further tricks here
so you have typically two kinds of
foreign entities where you do offshoring
you can have an independent foreign
contractor
you know and those advertise widely you
know and
you know tata and all kinds of people
have
have companies that focus on that
if you have valuable intellectual
property you probably prefer to set
up a controlled foreign corporation a
cfc
then they're your employees that still
doesn't guarantee
completely that no ipa were lost but
you're in much more
more control it's very hard for a
contractor
who works one week on your stuff the one
next week maybe on staff of a
competitors
you know to keep keep the intellectual
noses clean
of course once you do the cfc
you you also establish a little tax
haven
where the rights to the ip are being
kept
and now we since we're moving this array
round we need to value things first of
all you have to value things because
once you move ip
somewhere else you're worried about the
risk of loss
having a 10 risk of loss is meaningless
if you don't know what the value is of
what you have to lose
yeah and and so a lot of these risk
type things are done very poorly so
so before you went what what all what
did mnc all do
i mean you he you design some things
you provide the design to manufacturing
operation
you know in malaysia maybe close to
singapore because that's
where there's a lot of shipping
available and good communication
you have software being done in india
and shipped to you the goods in malaysia
can be shipped directly
back to the u.s to europe to latin
america wherever you operate
this the software that you have you know
will be loaded probably directly into
your distributors so it's always up
you know up you know up to date
and the money from all those operations
flows to you in the silicon valley
next step you now have established your
tax
haven somewhere in the bermuda triangle
and so i call that company corns you
know there's nice shells on the beach
etc
right you and the only
thing that has changed that now all the
income
flows to to conch
right so there's this new intermediary
that you have
you know you know the orange coins there
that's where the money goes to
of course conch has to pay for actual
shipments and things that are being
built
at commodity rates but the rest
stays there nothing much has changed the
only thing that has changed
and quite invisibly to all the smart
engineers working at the company
is the initial transfer zero the rights
transfer
to the tax haven and where the profit is
being collected
steps one through five are unchanged
now there's a difference between
tangibles and intangibles
if you have a tangible you cannot cheat
too much of the value right if you ship
a locomotive
you know to an owner and the locomotive
is operated
in this country or even in another
country
you expect to get a price back that is
reasonable for a locomotive
if if you're a one million dollar
locomotive
appears on the book as a sale for
seventy thousand dollars
somebody would scratch their heads even
an irs agent may notice
that you've sold locomotives to the
united states at a million dollars
but you're selling locomotives to
a tax haven company for 70 000 and they
might catch you
however when you deal with intellectual
property
hey there's probably no experience that
the poor tax accountant has
right and and if you
you know commissioned a nice report from
one of your accounting firms
that convinces you that the value
of the same income let's say a million
dollars
but it's only worth 70 thousand dollars
you probably get by you know
in very many cases you get by because
the poor tax accountant
even if you notice it's funny
he's busy right he may not worry about
it
if he thinks that finally he he may tell
his manager
the manager says oh don't bother me we
have to close the case we have a big
workload
maybe the maybe the manager is really
concerned
and he goes up to his district manager
and if the district manager doesn't say
you know
don't bother then it may go
to the right division in washington
and then it might be investigated i have
a contract with that division
furthermore often ip doesn't have an
equivalent or established market value
to begin with well
if it's new ip and no one's ever done it
before
there you can't in the market no you can
you have to
it's not easy that's what i'm talking
about
you can't compare it's not quite
okay so the principle of a value of
something is very simple
the value of an asset whether it's
tangible intangible
is the indiscounted income that it will
bring into the future
that is true for building
it is true for books that you've written
it is
true for any intellectual property
the wisdom of the masses actually has
some sense of that
right because thereby if it's a public
company
they buy shares they buy shares on the
expectation
of deriving future income from that
they may be stupid and they may be
lemmings but get enough livings together
they're often more or less right
right so a first thing to look at if
it's a public company
and if the rights to the entire company
are being sold
which is often true then you first look
at the market value
now you choose your german company
because i can't mention any american
companies
right they have
a you know the shareholders based on the
price of shares that's
already from 2005 was 31
something euros you look at the books
are the assets that appear in the books
that are counted slow about
right that was
6.38 i think
billion euros i think actually
and what's left are the intangibles
the invisible stuff right
no that's 80 that's not an
atypical number for a company
in fact it's somewhat low because sap is
old-fashioned
and they they own their own buildings
etc and they own their own computers and
other companies release buildings and
these things and they have even
even lower ratios of tangibles
you know essentially all you need is
yellow pad right and
and you can lease your desks
so such a ratio is kind of typical
now the quest is how much of that is due
to software
how much is due to hardware well sap
doesn't make hardware so it's easy
and how much is due to people
i use one company which is a drug
company
you know they fall into exactly the same
pattern
and that was actually publicized
somewhat incompletely by
you know by businessweek but but i could
also look
at the annual reports that are submitted
to the sec so i could complement this a
bit
what business week missed was this
transaction zero
where the ip rights are forest labs
a drug company in missouri
transferred its rp rights to
forest labs holdings in available in
bermuda
now with drug companies that's the point
you were making
it's very hard to value a drug you know
a very very good time to value it
is when the fda hasn't approved it yet
right so so you move it over
and and
and the holdings company buys the asset
rights i don't know how much they paid
for it
my my typical example in cases that i
see
that the payments are five percent of
the actual future income
maybe seven percent now what happens
is you know the drug comes out this is
from the business week diagram
somebody in phoenix pays 99 percent for
what do they make levator or something
like that you know
you know the drug is keeps some money 76
dollars goes to the headquarters
you know in in new york there's some
operations and marketing costs
the pills actually manufactured in
italian ireland
so they transmit the money to europe
and in fact it looks as if it's going to
ireland but it actually
sneaks under the ground to the
netherlands
because they don't want the irish tax
people
to know what is involved so there's
another company
called forest finance amsterdam i walked
by the address
it's a it's a bank building with many
offices
the name is not on the door they
probably have
no employees there right what does
forest finance
holdings do it cost about
18 bucks including the markup
to manufacture the drug so they transfer
18 bucks per pill
of a box of pills to ireland
the remainder 44 goes to bermuda
ireland has to pay a license fee
for the rights to make the drug
right so 12 also goes to boom
also goes to bermuda
the irish tax authorities only make
money on a five percent markup because
making the drug is a commodity
process anybody can do it they collect
the
12 and a half percent low income tax
so they get cheated as well
people in indian ireland didn't mind
being cheated because it created jobs
okay and that's still you know a benefit
for these countries
and so they're not going to investigate
very deeply what's happening
the the operation in
valine bermuda has to pay something to
the people that actually work
in saint louis missouri it turns out
that is seven dollars
pope you know per pill
and there's a mark up there in the end
the united states
now realize this is an input and it can
it gets
one dollar nine cents
from the 99 sale
how do things get misvalued
i told you the rule for for valuing
things
first of all you ignore the human
capital
you know because that's even less
visible than intellectual property
you ignore ongoing research because
that's income in the future and it
doesn't
you know and it's typically expensed on
the books of companies so so that's just
ongoing expenses
you you said whether you change the lag
that
you know the delay time that you've
spent money between
investment and getting the money back
that gets a bit more complicated then i
won't go into that
you you diminish the value of the ip
rapidly
oh this drug will only live for
you know we have a market for uni you
know five years because we
we patented we issued the patent 15
years ago there's only
five years to go on the patent
of course you know a different
formulation of the same drug etc
will come out so the effect of life will
be longer
you can use a high discount rate you
know that's a typical financial thing
you can mischaracterize the ip license
at being non-exclusive available to
anybody
but of course who you actually sell it
to
is well is up to you and you certainly
wouldn't sell the license
to anybody but your own subsidiary
a non-exclusive license has a much lower
value
you know maybe 30 percent of an
exclusive license but you are the only
one
that can make profits from it you
allocate little income to the offshore
sales
you don't adjust for some changes
uh you you you where you make funny
interest rates
you see if you were to license that to
an independent company
they would have to pay pay for that
right
that means they would probably have to
get a loan
right and the loan depending on the
credibility of the company will be
anywhere
between twelve and eighteen percent
but since it's your own company you can
lend them the money at one percent
so you lend the maximum money at a
discount rate in order
to to sell your ip
cheaply to your own subsidiary
all these factors change evaluation
you know by anywhere from 10 to 50
percent
once these all get multiplied by each
other
you typically are left with 10 to 5
percent
that is the range i've seen i would say
at least seven percent is typical
it depends how imaginative you are how
early you
transfer the iep you know
so so to assess the ip
the formal way is to do an income come
projection
now many companies when they have a new
product
before investing in its development make
income projections
you know they may not be true
but they are available
and and that's an advantage of working
for the treasury
you if there's a question you have the
right to request
any document that was used in the
company
you know doing its development can be
like pulling teeth
can take extremely long
they may deliver it in illegible formats
that you can't scan
but but you have a right to get you
don't have the right to
ask them to generate new documents and
new analysis
you have to do all the work you yourself
so but once you have that data
and you can also compare now whether
these numbers are reasonable with other
similar products
you know but by the time you worry about
taxes you're probably a major company
the other
similar companies that you compare
things so you can show
to when things are you know are very
wrong
so that's what you do in order to do
evaluation
it will never be precise
but it will but you can make it credible
and especially if you find
funny things in the way the orange
evaluation was done
those you can correct and often just
doing the corrections gets you up to
you know from 7 to 50 percent
another way is to do r d rollover
you have invested in r d for this and
you expect the payout
if the value is so low that your r d
has a negative payout you're pretty bad
businessman
you know uh so
the payout should be anywhere from 1.2
to to factor 10 if you invest in r
d you know due to all the discounting
and all the
nasty things but obviously
and people that understand it are the
venture capitalists
they would not invest in your company
unless
there's a good chance of an average
payout of a factor 10 because in a high
risk situation
they hope for a factor 100 sometimes
they lose
but on the average they win so there's
some information available
about r d leverage so that's another
thing you can use
and of course i mentioned always if it's
a public company
always look at the market capitalization
the people that you deal with may say oh
our stuff
our shareholders are stupid they don't i
don't know why they're paying so much
for our company
but then you look at al but at the at
the
annual report they send to their
shareholders and say how wonderful they
are you should buy more of our stock
and of course you you model other
existing businesses
you know in order to show what are
typical ratios
and actually business books are full of
all kinds of ratios
many of these ratios ignore intellectual
property
because that's not that easily found but
some ratios and some models exist
where you can look at so so you can do
something
you know saying it can be done is a good
inducement to get smart people
to actually work on it right
for for instance while in software you
can use a model
based on effort software has to be
continuously maintained
what you're selling at the initial point
is software that exists but then will
continue to be maintained
but why does it have to be continually
maintained
because the world changes i
i well i agree there's some
the well the science exactly but the
sign function that was written in the
1960s
doesn't need much maintenance anymore
actually
i wrote a very mathematical program that
did
the combustion equations for solid fuel
rockets it was used for the polaris and
the shuttle
and as far as i know it was it it had
minor changes because fortran kept
changing
you know but it's still so it didn't
require much maintenance
most other software
look look at software like word
right it's it's grown immensely
and the size is a measure of effort
most of the reason that word changes is
because
otherwise people wouldn't buy new
versions right
so they add new features and some of
these features were
you know very useful you know lawyers
couldn't use word
until they stole a feature from
wordperfect which allowed strikeouts
and double strikeouts right they added
that
it it it lacks their market there's a
lot of stupid thing
going on but if it adds a five percent
segment of the population
so it keeps growing at the same time the
price doesn't keep going
word today costs about the same
inflation adjusted certainly as it did
when it came out
20 years ago but you're not mentioning
liability
or are you gonna say that later no i'm
not talking about liability
on the whole i don't deal much with
costs where we're you know with
risk costs okay
so so so that is one model you can use
you you often you have to take the time
this is actually a cost function how
long it
how long you have to invest to get
something out
and then you look at that that the
company is it a startup
a startup tends to grow slowly
that's the bottom line and then do
testing
and then in the end just before it comes
out have a very high growth curve
actually a limit of a startup before it
comes out
is that the growth curve cannot be too
large otherwise
people step on each other's feet and
you've probably seen examples
of that if you have a mature company
you have people around that have worked
with each other you still have a startup
you have an initial growth limit so you
can model
how these investments go
investments delay the time that
transferred ip
yields income
so that can make a very big difference
to the thing so so you put them all
together you first have a
simple model of how the value goes down
that's the bottom purple line then the
black line
you move things over because of that lag
things but then often
products don't get move you know move to
foreign
until they're somewhat mature
in fact now you you you probably
recently read in the new york
times about the microsoft subsidiaries
round island and flat island most
nominally based in ireland
you know so those were not established
until about word three or four
at that point word didn't change that
much anymore so now your baseline
is the lowest lower red line adjusted to
the transfer date
and that's now the hundred percent so
the
so the rate of loss of ip over time
changes and
another frequent case of of you know
saving on taxes this
as well as doing some misallocation and
when i make
here here simple example
you you you you have a business jointly
with an operation in canada
the car was crashed but you
and it needs a 600 door you can't find
it
but you can buy for five thousand
dollars you know a wreck
in the united states take the door out
bring it to canada
or you know legitimate expert
you have your car in canada again
now you charge your u.s division the
five thousand dollars
cost and you book a six hundred dollar
profit
from the income you got from canada
canada will pay taxes
accordingly the us will pay but you get
a nice tax deduction out of this
a bit simple example but those things
happen all
over the place especially again with
intellectual property
which can be invisibly chipped back and
forth
you know you you buy a little subsidiary
that helps you make your products
becomes nearly invisible what's going on
that previous example wasn't legal right
that depends on who you talk to you
if you have a good accountant he'll
defend you
things are marginal right this is not
i wouldn't consider that appropriate i
don't make decision over the one thing
things are legal i'm not a lawyer i only
point things out
there's something funny going on that
doesn't make
business sense outside of taxes
and there's a general rule but it's very
hard to say
that transactions that are obviously
only for taxes
are questionable well it works if you
bribe the taxman
right we've been doing everything legal
actually american tax people are pretty
hard to bribe
on the other hand uh what on the world
scale
on a word scale yeah
now i'm looking at what happens overall
to the us
these are corporate worldwide data
they come from inconsistent sources so
don't get them down to the
zeros to the lowest percents you know
because
they don't appear in any single document
you have a company there's worldwide
earnings
of no no this is the total worldwide
and i averaged about five years but that
took
no six years but it took two years out
when there was a big
problem with you know with with the
economy
so the average is that oh yeah
so i took out 208 209.
worldwide's earnings were 1.5
trillion dollars per year about 1.25
came from domestic sources
no problem
there there were eight 1.8 of that
was actually income from you know
you know earnings on foreign income from
foreign sources
and then there were things that was
really
us income which pretended
to be foreign like the forest lab
example
forest labs until recently didn't sell
any drugs in well outside of the united
states
you know but all its income was declared
to be foreign income
so so what happens you know the u.s
companies
you know the pay pay the nice bronzing
taxes and that's in the revenue that
goes to united states
in addition about 5 billion goes
from u.s tax on you know properly
declared foreign income
uncollected tax is substantial
uncollected tax on u.s earnings that
pretend to be outside of the united
states
is also substantial so so what happens
after everything is done and
for this company 620 billion is
available
for corporate dividends and investments
in in the us 690
billion is available outside of the
united states
you know so so that is the and and
effect of that
now now now very quickly what to do
about it
there's an observation is that the
share of taxes paid by corporations has
been decreasing
if there's a linear extrapolation which
is probably invalid because things never
con you know continue linearly they
speak about but if they were the
decreasing in corporations would already
be paying no tax whatsoever by 2050.
you know they they they used to pay a
much higher fraction
of oh you know of u.s taxes but they but
they become more efficient
infinitely efficient so what are the
effects over time of course
that capital builds up offshore rights
to intellectual property builds up
offshore
that allows more investment offshore
that allows more generation
offshore at what rate that will happen
you know i cannot predict who pays taxes
well employees both employed by the
government and businesses
shareholders pay taxes but shareholders
although
also get dividends on which they pay
taxes at a lower rate and then there's
independent workers
hired by businesses or the government or
whatever
so they all pay taxes you know there's
much yelling that this double taxation
of people that are shareholders because
the corporation also pays taxes
i i have the amounts for these actually
well in my book
so that was not the intent at
all when i started writing and do my
analysis
i have all kinds of nice recommendations
on how to improve the system
make valuation more fair make things
more transparent
allow the res to be more efficient etc
and in the end i stated that none of
them work
so i had a radical proposal
do away with corporate taxation
but pay full rates on dividend and
capital gains taxes
it turns out that the back of the
envelope estimate because
it will be a process over time you know
that it looks that you'd be only losing
about
five percent of total actually half a
percent of total tax revenues
over time corporations will have to
adjust
they will have to pay higher dividends
to compensate the people that are now
getting dividends
so they receive the same money you see
i'm not trying
to screw the people that are receiving
dividends
and especially not all the pension funds
because that's what i live on these days
right but it would equalize
multinational and domestic corporations
would it would remove the motivation to
use tax havens
and and i'm assuming that some of the
money would flow back
not instantly like i've said i heard
some police politicians claim
my my model gives a ten year line for
the mov
you know money moving it would be
disaster if all the money moved in
because there's not enough things to
invest it
until the economy wants to buy things
but to a certain extent we'll just
advance what's happening piece of meal
so now i have the motivation to the
initial questions
is it up is it all legal
so it seems all legal after the initial
misvaluation
which unfortunately occurs so much
earlier
that it can never be undone you know the
business has
counted on a model
that used that
it turns out the you know the amount
that 40 percent would go back
is also not true because even though
that 40 percent
for federal and state taxes is a
statutory rate
there are enough exemptions that
businesses actually pay
on the order of 25 taxes
so the big announcement from senator
camp about
lowering the corporate tax rate to 25
percent
has essentially zero effect once once
you look at it
especially if you remove some of the the
tax exemptions for cooperation
but it sounds wonderful can
the loophole should be plugged what i've
described is not a loophole
it's a process and you cannot
undo a process that started many years
ago
all large u.s multinationals now have
but nearly all large u.s multinationals
have substantial tax havens
and they couldn't compete without it i
mean
if you would tell yahoo to stop it's tax
haven operations
and say but that's unfair google has
them right
and if you then tell google to stop it
says well it's unfair
because etc
and so the only people that don't have
tax haven at the moment are the small
corporations
and actually the accounting firms are
very aggressively marketing to smaller
corporations these days
because they have all the big
corporations already in their pocket
and they have the intellectual capital
to to to rapidly
make you a tax-free corporation by
setting up a subsidiary in the bermuda
triangle
i already mentioned that ireland having
a 12 percent corporate tax
rate should change it first you can't
change it that's a sovereign country
you know you you cannot change the
cayman islands it's a sovereign country
and it became as it proclaims frequently
when it's being attacked i have nice
quotes
from the i forgot what the name is so
it's not a president there island but
ireland has territorial taxation which
means ireland does not collect taxes
from companies outside of its physical
boundaries
so that is why the subsidiaries in
bermuda
are typically round island
at a flat island are typically
subsidiary
of an irish corporation not of a u.s
corporation
because ireland won't collect taxes so
you
so the u.s corporation actually owns the
irish corporation
which owns the bermuda corporation
because ireland won't collect taxes
and then the sales taxes assumes that
that there are no transfer and of course
when you buy things on the internet
god knows where it is and where it's
booked
okay geography is no longer a limit in
this world
okay boy 516. i'm one minute over
what 5 30 oh 5 30. okay then i have time
for questions good
i thought i had to talk to 5 16. so this
is an old quote
from an english magazine you know
any questions
well you're you're you haven't mentioned
dead in any of this
and to a considerable extent where uh
corporate profits are not are paid out
not through dividends but they pay for
their capital
as debt or as stock buybacks yeah
and those uh many corporate
decisions are driven by the fact that uh
debt is taxed at a much lower rate than
uh dividends
by the way i understand in my book the
capital gains issue itself
is a very funny one because people say
it
travel gains a double taxation which is
not true
because it's paid for by tax-free money
the fact that corporations can
accumulate that
to an extent that you can't you know and
consider the business expense
is an advantage for them and so one of
the things that i address in my book
actually specifically
if that would happen banks would lose
some of their power in fact
banks are worried about that
because you know they are the issuers of
that
and they count on it and they say but
but you need us because we're doing such
a wonderful world
in order to protect our debt we're doing
such wonderful work
in order to supervise the companies that
they're not doing funny things
okay
selling toxic assets so
so so that is an issue and i address it
somewhat
it's a complex issue it interacts indeed
with that
and i don't put it specifically in
velvet in
within my model if you make a model with
too many parameters
you know then it becomes very unstable
do you think that all
all forms of paying for capital should
be taxed equally
women are taking capital
in principle yes but you must be aware
that i only deal with corporate taxes
so actually and i talk also more about
that
the homeowner who buys a house and sells
it later
at the nominal profit should not be
taxed
or probably on the rate that is purely
due to inflation
right but that's a very long-term
holdings so
there are proposals and i cite some of
them in my book
to to have capital gains indexed
by inflation rate or something that
would also do away with
the fact that now you you get capital
gains if you
hold money only for you know for one
year
right which is not whereas capital gains
somewhere to having lower type of gains
like and somewhat motivated
you know to make long-term investments
but but obviously
you know what one year money you
you know that's you know does not build
a company does not build an economy
etc
so i'm interested in i i see a very
financially oriented view here yeah but
the value creation paradigm
potentially transcends money entirely in
its most effective forms i mean
we can see the open source uh
money is still uh paying people's light
bills here
but in an open source economy one
leverages
the marginal cost of replication of ip
and recognizes the economics are
fundamentally different
so if we're interested in designing
economies which perform
well is it valid to use conventional
economics in the old world
sense in order to build new world
economies
first i would argue i'm not quite doing
old birth cents
i'm doing doing
20 at least early 21st century sense
it is beyond me to change the global
economy and to
build a completely different system this
proposal that i'm making
is not is deals with corporate taxes
it is relatively simple very few laws
have to be exchanged
there are millions of regulations that
become
moot if the corporate tax rate is zero
about 5 000 pages of tax regulations
you know you know you know you know go
out of the window
we may be because they're all multiplied
by you know by
by by corporate taxes and now
before a corporate tax attorney right
but think of the poor corporate tax
attorney
yeah no in fact in fact i will address
that
remember ge has as many people
working in the tax office as the irs
has to check all of the u.s large
corporations
but they're actually very smart people
and i and that's why i stayed in book
i'm confident they can get jobs
but what changes intellectual property
law
so the shape of our intellectual
property commerce
is profoundly different these models are
rather inapplicable to
a new world information economy right
but i don't know what the new you know
that's that goes beyond my dealings
you're right
i'm talking for finance i'm talking
corporate taxation
you know and and so i try
if even then it's a 500 page book
just to deal with that right
but i cannot deal with the rest of the
world and then
people sometimes they deal with the rest
of the world don't go into situations
that's well wealth of networks is a 400
page book which
is a nice counter balance yeah you've
read it yet i have and i've read that
somebody has recommended it yeah
it's definitely good okay no no no and i
think other economic models are possible
but to move to them would be
considerably
even even what what i am proposing is
pretty radical
but i think it could be achieved not in
the current political scene
but right so how much of a
typical big corporate's you know
management budget goes for all those
lawyers that you said gene
oh it's a small fraction you know you i
think
ge has about 800 people working in its
tax department
and of course the tax department is
headed by a former irs commissioner
right and though and they're well paid
people but it's probably
i've never met this probably less than
maybe about one percent
of ge's employees you know
and it's very profitable you know those
people
may make more profit you know per work
hour for ge
than any of its other employees
no but if we if we ask
your suggestion to congress uh and these
guys are now out of the job
well let's show up on um
you know i i doubt it it's
since it's less than the engineers that
are put out of
jobs you know by you know you know by
you know by you know
essentially by moving ip around now
again you know
and any change cost somebody but but
these are smart people
uh actually that's actually one of the
fun jobs that
the lawyers of the companies that i
enter in interact with
are intellectual giants you know
if a company can save a billion dollars
by hiring a million dollar lawyer
right those are really smart people and
and the and i admire them and then some
of them know me when i
go to san francisco airport and i see
them you you know they wave at me
it's a it's a relatively small clique
because they're all
it's a small group that does a heavy
intellectual works for
all kinds of people but by the way those
organizations
are nicely organized if you look at the
fine print
many of the many of the organizations
are organized as a swiss club
it's a club of their businesses where
the members are
the us division the cayman islands
division the swiss division
the european division the netherlands
division the uk division
why is it organized as a club so they
can sell their yachts
no no no no i mean this is this really
is your name about your young money
you are saying about value creation you
think about real things
i i read books like wealth of networks
which talk about the future of
information
and how it's so radically different than
a physical goods economy
the reason they are organized the clubs
is for liability
if you're a member of a club you can
share
in its proceeds you can control the
membership
you can allocate resources among each
other
but you're not liable so if
the club member company in the
netherlands tells you to do
x and y and you do it
in the u.s
the the the u.s company doesn't have
liability
oh no that was done by a club member of
mine in the nestles
well i'm sorry even though we're members
of the club as a club member i'm not
responsible what my
dear fellows are doing in the
netherlands
toxic assets are also an opportunity i
mean why don't we just go back to
selling toxic assets
i mean i i think again that is beyond
and i'm not talking about doing anything
criminally illegal cheating anybody
explicitly i'm just trying to explain to
you how
how the system works at 5 30 they
stopped recording and then you can tell
us you know what you really are
you certainly won't say anything illegal
on the air
i won't say anything illegal anywhere
i've well i've worked with clearances
saying i got my first clearance
top secret kids in 1957 and i know how
to show
oh i know what i can say and what i
can't say
you're not supposed to reveal sources
and methods that's the fundamental thing
and names well that's source
what grew you into this field most
computer scientists i know
would just avoid economics and tax
theory
uh two reasons
you know before i became a professor i
was in in corp
in corporate work and i had moved out to
the level
that i was becoming a manager and that
was frustrating frustrating
because it only deals with people issues
all the time
and whereas research progress is much
slower than what people think
progress in human behavior is still
cheap
anyhow so so i had some background
the other but it's purely an accident
a lady who was working for miter who
does a miteless consulting for the irs
uh wanted
said to get out of it and the reason i
know is because
we have interlocking patterns on this
you know you know
available some security technology you
know
and uh
she she wanted to leave she wanted to go
to nsf then sf wanted me to go to nsf
because
i've been funding the digital library in
darpa
and since that became quite successful
you know
and herself wanted me to become a
program manager i didn't want to move to
washington
she wanted to move to washington we
essentially we recommended each other
and we lived happily ever after
all right and
you're right most computer scientists
lois talking about money when i address
that thing to some very smart people
they say oh i let the accountants worry
about it
that's why i gave you perlis's epigram
most
most all programmers think that way not
just list the programmers
so obviously economics and game theory
are related and being a bright
gentleman who's probably contemplated
the relationship between these two
can you abstract this back to
the competitive nature of economics and
how
game theory might like help us get
somewhere
frankly i haven't done that that would
be my father's side
there are obviously games being played
you know but whether i have been
formulated
and you know it's game theory
you